new professions are born to understand
how much a single
component single customer will cost in a
complex cloud environment
and it's it's becomes very complicated
to manage to efficiently manage
your infrastructure while maintaining
the business needs
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
let's talk about developers
meet maxim melamedov ceo of zesty
maxim is a husband and father of two
sons he aims to surround himself with
people who are passionate about shaping
the future love to learn about work and
life and see the joy of being a part of
a great team
today he is the ceo of zesty and started
it with a clear mission to help
engineers automatically keep their cloud
infrastructure up and running while
staying within budget on a personal note
maxim definitely curses too much and
waffle between believing that it's a
gross deficiency or a great trait for
which his grandchildren will fondly
remember him
meet maxim
i really appreciate you coming because i
know how busy it is and i can only
imagine how
how busy it gets
running a company that has raised a
significant amount of money 35 million
dollars just in their in the most recent
series a round
for some fantastic partners in the
ecosystem doing something that that is
not just innovative but but i think it's
also just interesting in the in the way
that that is enabling other companies
around the world to develop technologies
cloud-based infrastructures we you know
we've been hearing in the last few years
about what's been happening with devops
teams and the shortage of understanding
and and manpower that we have in in
managing the cloud infrastructures and
so i'm really curious to pick your brain
as to where this industry is headed and
what's happening today especially with
zesty so maxim thank you very much for
being here
awesome thank you for having me
founding of zesty and you yourself were
you always into cloud infrastructure and
and this type of work
no actually my background is is
is
a bit different than your typical
entrepreneur especially in the
in the in the cloud infrastructure space
uh i come from an entrepreneur family my
dad is an entrepreneur he was he founded
the business in the soviet union which
was a capitalist a socialist state
but you know it was always in the veins
and it was always in the family so my
mom had a business and my uncle has a
business so it's always was i was always
surrounded by entrepreneurs
and i started my first business after i
i finished my army service
it didn't work as well as as i wanted
and
then i spent five and a half years
in homeland security traveling to
interesting countries
doing fun
and after that i decided that well it's
time for me to learn what it means a
startup what is a startup how a startup
is structured how it's built
and i spent around three years in the
startup world doing customer facing
positions i went from
a support team lead to
vp customer success
and
at that point i understood that well
there is a problem that
i saw in in in both
in both chairs i saw the impact of the
problem in both chairs
i understood that
the partner that in this journey is the
right partner
through the same mindset but a very
completely skill set completely
different skill set
and we understood that well
if there is a challenge
that everybody's facing and it's big
enough and it's in the most
innovative proven
technology well this is time for us to
jump out and start our own journey
right and so
you're you're entering this journey
besides you know with a great team and
with a great place where are you
specifically in your own sort of career
trajectory as you're starting this
journey are you starting it out with
with anticipation for what type of
milestones you personally want to
achieve or what types of things you know
what types of strengths and weaknesses
you may come in with
yeah we i understood that at the end of
the day
i've learned a lot from my previous
managers in i would say most of them
in all of my positions
two of my higher two of my managers that
hired me and managed me
throughout my career are actually
currently working with me at zesty
amazing uh
at the end of the day the weaknesses
that i have
are
i i
know most of them
and the way i overcome them is i bring
people that
their strength is my weakness
so it it creates kind of a puzzle where
we complete each other
from a skill set standpoint
but
the
the bigger value the most the more the
important things the mindset is very
very similar
and very very cool it's it's kind of
creating this puzzle of mapping the
right people
and getting to know them getting to
understand their priorities to
understand that your priorities meet is
identical to their priorities or as
close as possible
and this is in a way how we build the
company
amazing now
if we're looking at zestina from 30 000
feet in the iron we're looking at the
cloud
infrastructure space
how would you define the space today or
the problem space that we're in as we're
now entering 2022 and pretty much
we understand that the vast majority of
the world will if not is already on
built on cloud infrastructure
so
if we go back a bit in time you would
see that aws came and said well we have
a lot of spare computers
we needed to have that for amazon let's
try to you know to offer that to the
market
and with the same philosophy of
amazon aws was actually born
of
offer new technologies more efficient
closer to the customers and the
customers will come
and on that philosophy you have
microsoft azure
google cloud ibm and other cloud
providers are actually pushing new more
efficient more innovative technologies
distributed all
over the globe trying to get as closer
as possible to the end user
trying to achieve a better performance
and a more efficient way
that would support innovation
and this this has been going since day
one of of
the idea of public cloud
with that in mind with that in mind
the adoption of the new technologies of
the or the new infrastructure
this is where it gets interesting
in order for a company to say hey i want
to use this i want to use that i want to
i want to do something i want to try out
it's it's
it's lands on the plate
of an engineer
now if this lands on a plate of an
engineer it lands along with
with development with testing with
security with compliances with all
a bunch of other aspects that he has on
his plate
and it it comes down to
well i have this i have that i have to
prioritize
what should what is more important
for me to maintain my business to
achieve
what is business requiring for me to do
and
the struggle of the engineer is actually
deals with prediction
because
cloud in theory and in reality you have
unlimited scale you can scale as much as
you need you have a limited
infrastructure
but it's down to the engineer to predict
how much infrastructure
the business would require at any given
time
on a cpu ram block storage level
now it's hard because you know business
is changing you have different trends
you have different use cases you have
billions of other
of different capabilities of different
workloads that serve different purposes
on the cloud but all of them in essence
run cpu ram
gpu network
block storage
and
it's hard right and and and the pride
and the mistakes that the engineers are
doing
the humanly the human mistakes
the price for them are happy one
because if you under pro if you under
provision right if you guessed
wrong
and you don't monitor that
part of your application
you would have degradation of
performance
your application would not work as fast
as you expect you have customer
frustration
it may actually crash
waking up you in the middle of the night
and you have to figure out how to
firefight that
and the way to firefight at the city
well i don't want to do it anymore i
would take a bigger buffer
and when you take a bigger buffer
you have the finance team you have the
budget controllers coming it's like hey
listen we're like we're not utilizing
that so you have to shrink it back
now not everything can be shrunk
and you constantly located in this
endless loop about
you predicting you provisioning
infrastructure
you're not being an engineer
because to predict and provision
infrastructure
when costs are associated with that
is a completely different
skill set
than a typical engineer has
so new professions are born to
understand how much a single
component single customer will cost in a
complex cloud environment
and it's it's becomes very complicated
to manage to efficiently manage
your infrastructure
while maintaining the business needs
because at the end of the day
engineers are there to serve the
business
right completely
now i if we're looking at the the space
today
obviously you know a lot of people are
understanding that this is where the
world is headed and this is what needs
to be done how do you make sense
of of everything that's going on around
us because like zesty we have we have
other players that are coming in
offering similar tools and sometimes
even for me as an engineer and and and
you know i love this type of thing it
gets confusing making sense of what is
the right solution for which company so
so even putting zesty aside for a second
how does one you know perhaps a
r d manager or manager of the of the
devops team within an organization how
does one even go about trying to assess
what is the right tool for them and more
importantly than that what is the right
issue that they're trying to solve
within their organization
so
in regards to cloud costs
it's
i hope it's not far-fetched but it's
kind of similar to security
you have more than one place that you
need to do something to make sure that
you are in a happy place
you have endpoint security you have zero
trust you have you have different lever
the layers
same goes with
with the infrastructure you have your
application layer you have your
infrastructure layer you have your
kernel layer you have a lot of you have
your operating system layer we have a
lot of layers
where one can say hey i can do x and if
i'm doing x i would be
able to save money save time be more
efficient get get more for the dollar
i'm paying so it's not
a one-stop shop for everything
it's complicated
right and so if you're looking at now
zesty and your strategy
to
be a player within this market as you
communicate with customers what is sort
of the
the process that you go through with
potential customers as you're trying to
discover together
what is the right solution for them and
whether zesty is the right solution
so the way we are going with customers
is we're trying to to identify the pain
because it always comes with
how often does that happen how often
does this happen how how uh
how successful are you by doing
achieving this
at the end of the day it's very easy for
us to explain technology to the
engineers by saying hey do you do x y
and z
yes how often do you do that
like once x amount of time often what if
i'll tell you that we have an algorithm
that does that
every minute
every five minutes so it's more accurate
right it gets you lower smaller
granularity it achieves but it achieves
better results
so it's not something that i'm telling
you like a black box that that does do
the magic it's on the contrary i'm
saying this is exactly what our system
does or as much as possible in proximity
levels but it does it more frequently
in smaller granularity achieves in
achieving better efficiency
so
try it out
right what what is a growth strategy for
a company like this
what if we're thinking you know two
three years you know into the life of of
zesty
so
in a way we have i would say three three
main
main drivers the first driver is the
cloud provider themselves
they are very keen
to make sure they have
happy customers
so we are leveraging
cloud providers marketplace and we're
leveraging our connections
with them and
actually they're promoting us
so this is one pillar
the second pillar is to build
a relationship with managed service
providers
that are helping
small medium enterprises to actually
build their product
in a right way during the initial parts
of the cloud journey
and the third which i would say the most
important one is actually focus on the
journey and the brand
we
decided that
we need to
go and understand and live
engineers day-to-day
how they think how they like to consume
information what types where
we understand that engineers the last
thing they want is to have someone else
picking into their infrastructure
looking in what they're doing because
it's sensitive data
so we're trying to create
as lean and a simple
exploration process where
don't give us anything just go look into
something that you already have and
possess
look at your reality but from
our point of view and if you don't like
your reality
well you can
have us look into your you can invite us
to look at your reality and show you how
we can make your reality a bit better
right
the role of of brands within the types
of companies such as zesty
you're talking about you know trust and
brand identity and
it's it's it feels like there's a
dissonance here on one hand you know
it's not a traditional d2c or b2c
company and it's a deep tech company on
the other hand you do want people to
trust you as the ceo as you're moving
forward and striving forward
how big of a part is this when you're
trying when you're focusing the company
on on brand identifica identity versus
you know the importance of the
technology or the importance of the
growth of the sales teams
where is it in line with all these
different priorities that you might have
so
when you're small
you have to win
i cannot expect to have
company people that identified brand
they identify the logo can go in and log
and then start reading content
it doesn't work like that from day one
so you have to write your content you
have to start positioning yourself as
be as
a company that knows the pain that
understands the pain and understands the
day-to-day of a devops that understands
data of engineers
that speaks engineering
now while we do that we do
need to have
a go-to-market team that
does traditional b2b
because we need to get the logos the
first the early adopters the early users
to validate that the story we're telling
it has roots
and this is how we are actually be are
able to scale having validation from
cloud providers
saying hey this works we have happy
customers that can validate that zesty
ads value
we have
people who are reaching out to prospects
we and we're trying to build a brand
from uh
an outbound perspective
with that being said we are
creating content we are
doing thought leadership pieces
on
how we perceive the world of what
challenges we see and how other people
see the challenges and what means
innovate what it means to innovate
and hopefully
we would be able to
build
a
a user journey that is compelling enough
simple enough that resonates with a with
a large audience
of our community
fantastic
hey maxime i really want to
thank you for spending this time with me
and like i said in the beginning i know
how
very busy you are and and it sounds like
zesty is a
is another amazing story here from our
ecosystem about about building amazing
companies that are that are leveraging
very very cool technology to enable
other companies to also do the same and
and at the end having an impact within a
ripple effect and obviously zesty has
seen some tremendous growth recently and
congratulations again on your recent
raise and it was fantastic getting to
hear a little bit small part of your
story and your unders and your
value of what's happening now and so
thank you very much and stay safe and
stay healthy thank you so much
[Music]